الدكتور ارخبيل اليابان مثلا يقع على حزام
النار اكثر منطقه نشطه زلزاليا حول العالم
رغم ذلك عند وقوع اقوى الزلازل نشاهد
المباني الشاهقه تتمايل واكثر مرونه
وصمودا في وجه الزلزال ما سر هذه المباني
في ذلك ان اليابان تصمم مبانيها على زلزال
كانتو الذي حصل عام 1923 وهم يستخدمون
البنايات المرنه ويستخدمون مبدا العزل
الزلزالي للاساسات فعندما يكون العزل
الزلزالي للاساسات ممكن تخفيف مقدار
الطاقه الناتجه من الزلزال الى المبنى
بمقدار 80% فهذا عامل مهم من تخفيف
التعجيل الارضي القادم الى المبنى ومن ثم
تصميم المباني بحد ذاتها لكي تكون مرنه
طالما اشرت على ذكر تصميم المباني اليوم
في بيوت خصوصا خلال العقد الماضي يتم
تصميمها تكون فيها غرفه مضاده للحروب يعني
مثلا جدران حصينه ومنيعه وباب مضاد للرصاص
وكل ما الى ذلك هل يمكن تصميم منزل مضاد
للزلازل مئه في المئه او غرفه معينه يتم
اللجوء اليها نعم طبعا تصمم المباني بناء
على المدونات الزلزاليه فبلا شك يمكن
تصميم المباني القصيره او المتوسطه او
العاليه بناء على متطلبات الزلزاليه لكل
مبنى ولكل نوع معين بحسب وجودي بحسب شده
الهزات الارضيه في تلك المنطقه بناء على
مقدار التعجيل الارضي في تلك المناطق يتم
تصميم هذه المباني التي تفضلت بها